[Musique]
bonsoir mes chers petits amis nous
partons tout à l'heure pour un très très
long voyage mais nous reviendrons vous
voir
oui surtout si vous êtes très gentil
avec vos parents et avec tous vos petits
camarades aux nounours n'oublie surtout
pas de dire au revoir de ma part à
mirabel est apte il use je n'oublierai
pas patron j'oublierai voyons un aspect
qui lui même élu qu'est ce que ça fait
[Musique]
très bien et bea ça fait et à sa fait
beau élèves gaujour ce qu'on ne savait
pas notre leçon ça fait débat
[Musique]
les sévères se mettrent elle si l'or
dans la place au travail
soyons heureux et à sa fait oui
ouais à madame la maîtresse serra c'est
bien mon petit vous aurez une image
tellement au belge qu'est ce que c'est
ben c'est une bouille toute ronde avec
la mer autour tout bleu et des étoiles
la caisse qui était rigolo ce voyage
autour de la terre du bois la terre
c'est la boule et ça c'est la mer le
ciel les étoiles oui et tout à l'heure
que vous allez partir en voyage vous
avez sur le ciel sur la terre nous irons
tout autour de la terre dans le ciel
comme les avions comme les nuages
et comme les oiseaux exactement en fait
mais vous allez avoir fait j'ai toujours
faim piano c'est pour toi il us
je vous ai mis des armes ou des petits
petits globes loeb diop l'homme par qui
un fromage qu'au premier pour toi ou
merci les enfants comme c'est gentil
quelle bonne surprise ces milices qui va
être content tu diras discours est très
sage ou dire eh bien vous écrire à de
belles et où vous avez ras des beaux
dessins koufra pauvres j'espère bien on
a vous reviendrez butin dans un bois tu
nous racontera votre voyage et une en
rapportera quelque chose il s'est promis
mais vous saurez bien sage et l'huître
amusement alors au dodo mènera les vous
d'auto
au revoir le cher péter à bientôt femmes
non non non non remise voyage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans son voyage nous allons faire
j'espère que vous serez très sage mes
petits amis et surtout que tous les
soirs vous irez vous couchez vite vite
[Musique]
alors allons gros ours ne sois pas
triste puisque nous revenons bientôt
voir petit louis mirabel et tous nos
petits et grands amis
tu as fait le plein d'essence ouais le
moteur marche bien oui alors en route
bonne nuit à tous
très très bientôt à bientôt
[Musique]
oh